hi I'm Erik Bosse and Jumanji the next
level coming this Christmas 2019 is the
sequel to the 2017 Jumanji welcome to
the jungle and just like that movie
ended up being a lot more entertaining
than I think anyone expected this next
level trailer is making a sequel look a
lot more entertaining than I think
anyone expected that's the Hollywood
secret apparently you just hover right
underneath the expectations then cast
your movie perfectly and everyone loved
it I'm gonna break down this trailer
explain how this Jumanji sequel is
changing the game who is playing whom
and who those whom's are playing whom
and some fun indiana jones easter eggs
that they were working into it I think
some other details you missed smaller
warning the kids have a nice speculation
ends up being right never lose your life
okay in Jumanji the next level Spencer
Alex Wolff has moved in with his
grandfather
Eddie played by Danny DeVito I like how
he has a bell to summon Spencer even
though they apparently share the same
bedroom the music in this trailer is
Tommy Edwards it's all in the game an
appropriate song title which was edited
to sync up perfectly with Spencer's
voiceover to describe the premise of
these films were different people
[Music]
grandpa Eddy's friend is Milo Danny
Glover gettin too old for this [ __ ]
and the visited by Spencer's friends
from the first movie fridge sir Darius
Blaine
Bethany Madison Iseman and Martha Morgan
Turner so in the basement and Spencer
has been tinkering with the game the
pieces of which she secretly kept after
they destroyed it at the end of the
first film Spencer is now missing and
now the teens get sucked back into the
game Martha is once again playing Ruby
roundhouse played by actress Karen
Gillan the Lara Croft style dance
fighter but this time phryges Avatar is
Professor Sheldon Oberon Jack Black the
cartographer whom Bethany was stuck as
in the first movie doctor smolder brave
stone Dwayne the rock Johnson used to be
Spencer but in the next level grandpa
Evie is playing him and Franklin Mouse
Finbar Kevin Hartz
was once fridge but it's now Milo so it
looks like a lot of the humor in this
movie will be Danny takes the rock doing
his best Danny DeVito impression Kevin
Hart doing his best Danny Glover
impression who you are we in Florida did
I it turn into some kind of a small
muscular Boy Scout but this does leave a
bit of mystery to Spencer and Bethany's
whereabouts now Nick Jonas is reprising
his role as the game character Jefferson
seaplane mcdonough whom the kid Alex
freak was first trapped in the game as
in the first movie Colin Hanks
apparently returning for this sequel as
Alex but I'm thinking Spencer could be
playing Jonas's character this time also
well FINA has been cast in the film and
I'm wondering if she's a secret playable
character who gets unlocked and that's
who Bethenny could be playing as it's
also possible that Spencer hasn't
actually been trapped in the game after
all maybe just went for a walk or
something or perhaps he could have
intentionally restarted the game due to
some kind of villainous plot his I saw
hereditary that kid could be evil Rhys
Darby is returning as the pilot guide
Nigel Billingsley and Daniel Ramirez has
been cast in an unknown role this
trailer features some new locations the
jungle setting was level 1 so the desert
and mountain terrains could be part of
further levels into the game in the
desert level they flee from these
ostrich things at a dune buggy which
could be a nod to the Jeep chase the
Jurassic Park in this case with Jack
Black in the backseat just like Jeff
Goldblum was saying let's go faster
let's go faster but the other location
is this mountainous one in which Martha
seemed Nunchuk in a guy in this mountain
bar setting which could be a nod to the
Raiders of the Lost Ark in which Indiana
Jones and Marion got in a fight and
heard Nepal bar in another sequence apes
were chasing them in these elaborate
rope bridge divided up in these crazy
segments it's just as impractical as
these levels always are in video games
but then notice how the rock pulls out
this knife presumably to cut the rope
bridge exactly like the movie dr. Jones
used on the rope bridge in the Temple of
Doom I'm excited about this movie but
comment down below with your thoughts on
this trailer follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA vox and subscribe to new
rock stars for breakdowns theories about
everything you love thank you for
watching and as much as i enjoy the
rocks take on Danny DeVito I kind of
would have loved to see the rock but
with Frank Reynolds voice coming out of
his mouth
I dropped my monster condom that I used
for my Magnum dong maybe he's some
different audio
[Music]